places
hi i'm maximo for fxguide.com for wired
for the amazon studios the man in the
high castle zoex studios provided the
visual effects work to recreate the
period drama
set in this alternate universe the set
extensions and environment work was
extensive
but for a host of unusual reasons
firstly the show was set in america but
shot in canada
with the story mainly playing out in new
york san francisco
and the mountainous canon city secondly
it was set in 1962
which means removing many of the traces
of modern day life
but it's an america that lost world war
ii an america divided by two global
superpowers of the show
germany and japan and finally that
wasn't hard enough as it was
for fairly obvious reasons many
locations that were scouted for the show
simply didn't want to have their offices
or buildings covered
in nazi swat stickers similarly some of
the canadian chinese communities didn't
want to embrace the imperial japanese
look
from the production's art department in
fact the more the production got into it
the more
key visual effects became even some
simple problems such as finding period
cars or planes or trains
needed to be rethought as 1960s cars
would not have actually developed and
been designed to look the way they did
had america lost washington to an a-bomb
and never had a
post-war boom instead suffering
occupation
and defeat the amount of hidden visual
effects in episodic television is
growing dramatically as companies such
as zoeck
allow stories as twisted as the man in
the high castle to be realized
on an episodic budget and allow us to
see the world of
author philip k dick from someone as
talented and as amazing as executive
producer
ridley scott the show has been a hit for
amazon who have already commissioned a
second series
for 2016. well please subscribe for more
behind the scenes action i'm mike
seymour for wired
i need answers
what if there's a way out for you for me
for everyone